hi alicia i admire what you do
so much and how do you see
the hope and confidence that you instill
into these girls
well at sister cities you know we're all
about empowering girls by building
singing communities
that really center their voices we've
got choirs in philly and baltimore and
camden
so we're we're all about inspiration and
using the power and stories
from our own communities to bolster us
we performed at carnegie hall
the kennedy center but our favorite
performances are the ones for our family
and friends right here at home
and so this is about you know just using
the power of community and connection
to build long lasting empowering
sick communities for girls and putting
them at the center of making change in
our world
i mean first of all i just want to say
that
the community you've built is so
powerful and you give back to these
girls
you give to the community why does
makeup give something to you
well you know for me like especially
living in a zoom box
as we've been all living on zoom when
when girls show up for rehearsal on
saturday mornings kind of groggy
the first thing they see is my face and
i want to make sure that they see me and
they know
i woke up early i prepared i'm excited
to see them
right i got a little fancy and i
am ready and i've got something special
planned for them and so that's
how i think about preparing for choir i
i really hear that and um okay just tell
me about your makeup area what's it like
well my makeup area probably needs
it's a little work it's um this is the
room where i get dressed in the morning
um but my makeup is kind of like high up
on top of these shelves
and there's a full-length mirror of the
side so i wind up doing a little bit of
like
dab dab color lean is this
it okay back back um just to kind of get
things so it's not very well organized
but um
but there's great lighting which is nice
alicia what i think you actually are is
quite organized but i'm wishing there
was more of like a vanity
a beauty moment a romance
maybe get out of the utilitarian and
functional and really set yourself up
in a spiritual way for beauty so i
reached out to
design expert and very good friend of
the show
um mikal and we actually have a whole
new vanity
um for you and michelle is here
right now hey
now alicia you look like a bit of a diva
i know
that makeup area that you have right
there is not how you want to live
no i i want to feel diva-ish yes
look i'm going to help you we're going
to help you live your best life so let
me show you a couple of changes that we
have here so before we even talk about
the makeup
do you notice this wallpaper right here
you have
gray walls and you don't look like a
gray type of girl so
we have given you some peel and stick
wallpaper
so you can plop it on the wall you get
tired of it you can change it out
now let's talk about that makeup area so
i think the biggest problem that you had
was
that vertical challenge too high exactly
so
what i've done is i've used a regular
round mirror
and i've brought that down one inch
below your makeup table
now i'm saying makeup table because you
didn't have that before but
now i've given you a desk and with a
desk i know you're probably like a desk
like why would we use a desk well the
great thing about a desk is it actually
has storage
can you grab this side over here
absolutely so
with the desk we now have
storage and it doesn't stop there we've
also got like i'm
a new yorker so it's all about you know
like we need to take advantage of our
vertical space we're always trying to
stack things so the same thing with your
makeup organizers just kind of getting
things
up off of the table and for you getting
them up off the wall
yeah so we want to there's like some
stuff you want to see and some stuff you
don't
exactly exactly and i think the key to
this and you know sitting in your
dressing room
lighting is key now alicia i know you
don't have the big you know
diva lights that we would have in a
studio but you can create that illusion
by adding sconces to the side of your
mirror
and just like that honey you can feel
like beyonce yeah oh that is very yes
that's divalicious right there
i love what mikael did i don't think
this is a design by drew this is
straight up a design by mikael
and when i got like the renderings um
i was about to like get involved and i
was like i'm not getting involved in any
of this this is so perfect mikel just
nailed it thank you alicia do you like
it are you happy
i absolutely love it pink is my favorite
color and what i like about it is that
you know those metallic touches
i love the floral but with the dark the
dark pattern in the background so it
adds an adult vibe
it's just it's kind of sexy and it's
beautiful
oh i love it um i absolutely love it
michelle you're amazing
alicia we're going to send all of this
to you
it's going to get installed it's going
to be done all taken care of for you as
you take care of everyone else
and i want you to go to our website to
learn more about sister cities girl
choir
this has been marvelous thank you so
much i can't wait i can't wait
thank you to macau
you